i just love you oh thank that's so sweet
you just do i just think you're so great
you're so real
you know you led us through an
incredible season
how are you doing you know i appreciate
that question first off but
i'm doing really well like i'm genuinely
happy
i'm genuinely happy i'm doing good i
love that
well the last time you spoke with et
canada was right after the finale
um how's everything going with zach good
choice by the way thank you
everything's going well i mean um we're
definitely
figuring out this uh
this new life for us i think um
we have a lot of adjustments we're
making right now we i just got back to
new york we were in la last week i had a
work week
um and right now he's at work and i'm
over here at work so
we're just trying to figure out this new
schedule the new norm you know what i
mean and still trying to
spice up in a relationship in a pandemic
and
with everything being closed and whatnot
so it's fun
it's like every other relationship in a
pandemic you know
we do this it's a little it's a little
wavy but it's it's a fun
way you know what i mean yeah but it's
real
and i think that you know coming off
what you came off of the show
it's good to get into that groove of a
real the real life
yeah no i mean honestly i i would be
worried if we were still
like kind of happy-go-lucky and still
like if we had like a surface
level kind of relationship you know to
where we didn't
push each other um to try to grow and to
learn about one another and we're doing
just that and so
we're doing well it's good all right so
i'm gonna ask what everyone wants to
know okay the wedding plans
where are we at what's going on what's
the dress look like like what's
happening
okay let's see let's see if i have an
update last night we were actually
talking about this
and he knows that we
i officially decided it's gonna be
between either the months of uh
april to july because everything else is
taken and all the other months are taken
but as far as um when that will happen
and maybe like a year from now we're not
really rushing
um to set a date right away i think like
first things first is probably an
engagement party
when we can have that you know with
their closest friends and family
um just because like the you know it's
been tough to be able to get everybody
in a room
yeah um but as far as like everything
else
i don't know i'm excited to start
wedding planning i love all of that i
love decor i love being creative and
like finding things that like nobody has
done before and just
i don't think he knows exactly what he's
got himself into
i love that leave a little mistake it's
a little surprise
just a little surprise so would you ever
if they came to you and said hey we'd
love to televise this would you do that
you know i thought about this because
somebody else asked me about this
at first i said no because i feel like
you know we've
we started a relationship on television
and we kind of want to keep something a
little bit intimate between us
but also at the same time the outpour of
love we have gotten and the support
is like insane and i would love to share
at least maybe a segment of it with
everyone
i mean and also like i i like to i like
to
have fun and be on tv and do all that
kind of stuff so why not it would be
kind of i say
do it i made the biggest mistake when i
got married that sounds awful to say
but i said no video cameras because i
wanted my whole life is on video cameras
i was like i just want pictures that's
it that's it
biggest regret i ever had the i i wish i
had the video i have no video
so do it on tv for all of us and for
yourself okay
i mean to be honest with you it's kind
of nice being able to like look back and
see us fall in love with each other
you know so if we can have
you know the wedding to do that too
that'd be kind of cool
all produced and everything
[Laughter]
i see that you're training for the la in
new york marathon
um is zach a good training partner or
are you training oh my gosh
like what's going on oh my gosh if you
want to ask me about training um
well because there's now snow on the
ground it's a little uh
you know this is where my orange county
girl comes out and i was like oh my god
it's cold outside like
it's really hard to train out there but
yes it's looking like
actually it's the london marathon and
the new york city marathon it is you
know once in november once in december
so i would
do one of the other um i don't know
which one exactly yeah i did tell zach i
would do the london
so um he is definitely
adapted to the cold weather and the
running he's pretty good at that
um but me it's a little bit slower um
i'm definitely waiting
for you know some warmth to open up
because we don't even have gyms to go
running so
it's kind of hard right now yeah no i'm
with you i
i wait i'd wait for the sunshine
i i agree i i support you in that
decision why thank
you let's talk about your podcast
clickbait
with bachelor nation tell us all about
it um and what do you enjoy most about
doing it
well yes so click bait it's been so much
fun
um it is the first podcast that i've
actually been like a
a host for um i guess hosted quite a bit
but
um the fact that i've been able to
really make this my own with my other
co-hosts has been so much fun
um we do have a segment on it that's
called the bachelor nation breakdown
where we talk about all the latest and
greatest things that is happening in
bachelor nation for that week um
along with talking about you know the
clickbait we all
tend to like fall in a trap of like for
that week
um the media is very good at coming out
with some like
clicky headlines and really a lot of
things you know a lot of things so
we pick one one once a week and we talk
about it and we kind of relate our lives
to it or
um either we intertwine it with our
guests
that we have on the podcast we have
guests every single week
it's just a fun pop culture podcast that
we just we just let everybody else into
our lives a little bit more
i love that yeah all right let's talk
about math season of the bachelor
what are your thoughts on the season so
far i know that's such a broad stroke
but like
what are your thoughts on this season i
think matt is incredible
i think you know on i think everyone has
to remember for someone
not being you know on the show prior to
and being the lead and taking on as many
relationships as he
is it's very hard and he's doing a very
good job
um so with that as far as like the women
i think it's a little catty um
you're not kidding i was so fired up my
mouth
two weeks ago was on the floor on the
floor i was like this does not bode well
for women like what is going on this is
not who we are
why is this happening right now believe
it's frustrating
i was i have i've had a walk away at
some point
this is ridiculous like i'm not watching
this anymore this doesn't make me happy
so um it's been pretty frustrating but i
hope that pretty soon here we start
seeing some like
actual love connections and seeing some
relationships start to form
um it's an interesting season thus far
but i'm excited to see who matt ends up
with or
how it goes down definitely i just want
those women to start representing women
better like come on
we it's about being supportive it's
about
yeah so i that's what i want to see
absolutely not putting each other down
and and you know calling each other
names or
making up stories about people that can
really ruin somebody's life
yeah and i think like even with being
with zach
um and him being an advocate for like
mental health and
things like that like it's definitely
opened my eyes so i'm just like you know
you guys like this
can have like a lasting impact on
somebody um
you have to be careful you just have to
be careful what you say about other
people
yeah and not just them it's a trickle
down to their families as we've seen
it's just it's
dangerous and it yeah there needs to be
some accountability there for sure
math season let's talk about um who
could potentially be the next
bachelorette there's a lot of discussion
about katie being
you know a possible option what do you
think
you know the other week i was talking to
lauren about it and she was actually the
single person that i chose to possibly
be the bachelorette and this was before
the rumor started circulating
um i just think that i love what she
stands for and how she's been so strong
about
supporting other women and um advocating
for what's right as opposed to just
feeding into the rumors so
that alone she has won my heart over so
since it is black history month we are
asking everybody to tell us
who are some people who who inspire you
in your life
um first off i would have to say my mom
um i you know she is definitely someone
that has
encouraged me to always be a strong
person in my own and owning who i
am and and whatever that may look like
and just be a strong woman
as far as other people let me think um
you know just recently i did
um an interview for
it was an naacp and i don't know if you
know of
foloque she is an actress um
and she has been just hearing her story
and hearing her stance on how she has
tried to break the norm she was in an
interracial relationship
and i feel like she was at she was
trying to show people
in the world like what that looks like
and how to be a strong black woman to be
within
a caucasian man and she was just so
inspiring with her words
and um i have now become a huge fan of
her who else do i think
um i also like in our franchise rachel
lindsay has been a huge
advocate for standing up for us
african-american women as biracial women
and um the fact that she has utilized
her voice
and um help bring light
and change the franchise especially for
me i mean she definitely impacted it for
my
path to be better than what hers was um
because there was a lot of change that
needed to be had i am appreciative of
her
who else am i appreciative of so many
there's a couple of people there's a lot
yeah definitely well i just want to say
again
you're such a light and uh it was such a
joy watching you but we just we wish you
the best as you continue on your journey
and hopefully i'll get to see you when
we can all see each other and you can
come to toronto oh my gosh
i would love to have never been to
canada sign me up
we're gonna make it happen that's it
that would be so fun
thank you so much for having me today
yeah thanks for being here